l'état condamné par la justice pour son
inaction contre les rodéos urbains
marciel marseille elle assez des
nuisances et du danger accru dans son
quartier une habitante du 15e
arrondissement de marseille avait saisi
la justice
le tribunal administratif a tranché en
faveur des riverains et a condamné
l'état à 10000 euros de dommages et
intérêts selon l'arrêté la préfecture et
des bouches du rhône a pris et des
mesures insuffisantes pour restaurer la
tranquillité publique
une décision qui ne satisfait pas la
plaignante je ne suis pas satisfaite de
cette décision dans ce genre de
procédure on ne peut avoir que de
l'argent or l'argent ne m'intéresse pas
cette compensation ne règle pas mon
problème
les rodéos continue et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec jean-pierre
colombien ce porte-parole de
l'association de policiers en colère upi
jean-pierre colombiès bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors d'abord votre réaction à ce
verdict du tribunal de marseille
écoutez c'est ce qui est quand même
assez surprenant on peut même dire que
c'est assez pathétique qu'il faille
attendre une décision de justice pour se
rendre compte pour constater que les
services de l'état on parle de la police
en l'occurrence l'on peut dire que plus
globalement les services de l'état sont
tout simplement tout simplement disparu
de certains espaces
le président en vient à l'instant de
parler de coster épidémie qu'on pourrait
élargir le propos avec lost heures
d'insécurité il ya des parties entières
de ce territoire national qui nous n'y a
plus de présence d'état purement et
simplement
c'est un constat qu'on peut étendre à
d'autres secteurs ya pas qu'à marseille
on l'a vu avec l'exemple de dijon il ya
un véritable problème en france
actuellement mais qui a qui a débuté il
ya quelques années une vingtaine
d'années environ pour des raisons
budgétaires
on a purement et simplement renoncé à
une présence de l'état visible dans
certains secteurs dans ses recoins de
quartier parce que dans certaines
communes et la question qui va falloir
se poser est de savoir si la population
est d'accord avec ce principe qui
consiste pour des règles budgétaires
écarté à retirer de ces espaces la
représentation d'état et l'exercice
régalien des pouvoirs qui sont les siens
c'est un vrai problème de société
vous savez
la france vit dans un espace de contrat
social qui étaient déterminés après la
guerre c'est un contrat très spécifique
très spécial quitte à ses propres à la
france qui était une chance jusqu'à
maintenant puisque c'est un système qui
est quasi unique en europe pour ne pas
dire pour ne pas dire dans le monde et
on sent que depuis une vingtaine
d'années il ya une volonté réelle de
renoncer à cette particularité pour des
motifs budgétaires et presque
philosophique dans ce sens où on veut
passer d'une société solidaire d'une
société où l'état assure la sécurité
pour tous à une société où finalement il
y aura beaucoup d'individualisme et une
prise en charge individuelle des
problématiques liées dévolu jusqu'à
maintenant à l'état gentil est un fief
je vais me faire l'avocat du diable si
l'état est condamné c'est qu'il ya eu
une faille du côté de la police qui n'a
pas agi en conséquence
non pas une feuille de la police
justement c'est là où les mots les mots
ont un sens
la police elle fait ce qu'elle peut avec
les moyens dont elle dispose or il vous
a pas échappé que la succession des
ministres de l'intérieur jusqu'à
maintenant est purement tu peux vraiment
une politique purement d'affichage
ça fait trois ans maintenant qu'on a
quasiment plus dans ce pays ministre de
l'intérieur ni même de ministre de la
justice monsieur darmana est l'héritier
philosophie d'un certain nicolas sarkozy
qui à désengager la police de proximité
des secteurs des quartiers et donc il
n'est pas surprenant il sera pas
surprenant qu'il ne faille pas
différemment de ce que fut ce que fit
pardon sur son maître à penser
on est dans le cadre aujourd'hui une
petite d'affichage de discours de
gesticulations il n'y a pas de
véritables mesures il n'y en aura pas
tout simplement parce que nous n'en
avons pas les moyens
donc dire c'est la faute à la police non
c'est la faute à la politique qui est
menée cette politique est pliée
invisible depuis les ardennes je peux
vous poser d'abord une question si vous
le permettez
est ce que vous savez vous-mêmes
aujourd'hui ce qu'est la philosophie
sécuritaire du président macron alors en
l'occurrence c'est moi qui pose les
questions mais pour revenir ce matin sur
un impôt pour revenir au sujet
jean pierre colombier justement à titre
d'exemple pour qu'on comprenne
correctement quels sont les ordres
donnés quand il ya des rodéos par
exemple mais les autres sont simples
c'est qu'on évite les incidents on évite
justement de d'aller au contact pour
éviter un accident qui pourrait être
mortelle et qui occasionnerait et toute
une polémique antipolis faut bien avoir
conscience aujourd'hui qu'on a jetée en
pâture d'institutions police au nom
d'une politique qui est purement de
maintien de l'ordre mais qui est à
géométrie variable en fonction des
personnalités qu'on a en face de soi on
l'a bien vu avec les gilet jaune où il
ya eu des instructions rigueur extrême
voire même limite avec d'andorre avec la
loi et puis dès lors qu'il s'agit de
deux jeunes délinquants de délinquants
tout court bain on est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus en retrait parce qu'on
veut éviter des sur incident et on veut
éviter des émeutes dans les quartiers
c'est tout c'est ça la réalité c'est
qu'on a on a tout simplement laissé ses
territoires à l'abandon au prêt je dis
d'ailleurs des d'une citoyenneté qui vit
dans ces quartiers qui subit ça et on
est on renonce à y faire régner l'ordre
républicain
le cha cha le premier ministre jean
castex accompagné du ministre de
l'intérieur et du garde des sceaux a
visité ya moins d'un mois le quartier
des moulins à nice dans le cadre d'un
déplacement sur la lutte contre
l'insécurité est ce que vous sentez
justement que le gouvernement met tout
en oeuvre
bien sûr que beaucoup de travail à faire
non je vous dis jamais non vie ne met
rien en oeuvre il a nommé des ministres
de l'intérieur qui n'était que des des
têtes de gondole de tête d'affiche que
gérard collomb castaner aujourd'hui
darmanin en tant que ministre de la
justice ont eu madame belloubet qu'ils
n'avaient aucune aucune véritable
connaissance de la procédure judiciaire
et on nous met aujourd'hui un avocat qui
n'a jamais caché sa sas à m de la
fonction publique et des magistrats
d'ailleurs son propos vous fasse état
c'est assez étonnant parce que on nomme
quelqu'un qui a eu son heure de gloire
médiatique au niveau du barreau et ce
fall staff des barrois des prétoires
aujourd'hui est supposé gérer
l'institution justice avec beaucoup de
sérénité ça ne sera pas le cas mais ça
ne peut pas être le cas parce que de
toute façon la philosophie qui gère tout
ça qui est au dessus de tout ça fait que
les quatre piliers de ce contrat social
qui sont la sécurité la santé
l'éducation et la jeu
six sont dans un état de paupérisation
extrême on ne réglera rien si on ne
prend pas le problème dans sa globalité
si on ne pose pas le problème de ce que
l'on veut comme société du futur
ce qu'on nous présente comme le monde de
demain où la société en marche c'est
tout simplement une société ultra
individualisés où justement les pouvoirs
régaliens de l'état sont en recul sont
en retrait si on veut changer le système
pas de problème alors à ce moment-là le
domine le président de la fuite n'a qu'à
faire un référendum est posé la question
à la population à la citoyenneté en leur
demandant oui ou non voulez vous passer
d'un système solidaire globale avec une
présence et une action de l'état visible
à une société individuelle et une prise
en charge personnalisée local des
problèmes de sécurité et de santé par
exemple
mais il ne le fera pas parce que on
avance à visage masqué on nous fait
passer ça pour une sous sous couvert
d'une modernisation de la société miss à
25 ans n'est pas une
nous vivons dans un recul considérable
de la sécurité dans ce pays tout
simplement parce qu on a substitué à des
règles de sécurité
solidaires des règles budgétaires ce cas
passez le mot de la fin jean pierre
colombiès merci infiniment à vous pour
cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes le
porte-parole de l'association de
policiers en colère au petit merci à
vous